>> THE VICTORY WAS SHORT-LIVED.
DEMOCRAT STARTED COLLECTING
SIGNATURES LAST NIGHT FOR THE
REMATCH IN NOVEMBER.
BRET.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
IN LESS THAN TWO WEEKS, VOTERS
WILL HEAD TO THE POLLS IN
WEST VIRGINIA TO VOTE FOR THE
REPUBLICAN THEY THINK MAY HAVE
THE BEST CHANCE AT BEATING
DEMOCRAT SENATOR JOE MANCHIN IN
THE FALL.
THE INCUMBENT.
THE TOP G.O.P. CANDIDATES ARE
OUT TRYING TO GET THE MOST VOTES
BUT AT LEAST ONE OF THEM RAISING
SOME CONTROVERSY OVER A COMMENT
HE MADE ABOUT SOMEONE IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CABINET.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY HAS
OUR REPORT FROM CHARLESTON.
>> IT WAS STRANGE TO SEE A HALF
TO SUPPORTING TOM WILLIS LAST
NIGHT BECAUSE TOM WALLACE WASN'T
WEARING IT.
IT WASN'T -- HE WASN'T INVITED.
THE CAP WAS SUPPORTED BY DAN
BLANKENSHIP.
>> IS A VETERAN, A GOOD GUY.
HE DESERVES AN EQUAL CHANCE.
>> NOW BLANKENSHIP'S ATTACK ON
THE ESTABLISHMENT IS RAISING
EYEBROWS BECAUSE THE FORMER COAL
BARON WHO DID A YEAR IN JAIL DUE
TO A CHARGE DUE TO A MIND.
TALKING ABOUT ELAINE CHAO, WIFE
OF SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL.
>> I HAVE AN ISSUE, THEY
FATHER-IN-LAW WAS A WEALTHY
CHINA PERSON AND A LOT OF
CONNECTIONS.
>> A FOX NEWS POLL FINDS THAT
BLANKENSHIP TRAILS EVAN JENKINS
AND PATRICK MORRISEY.
>> JENKINS IS A LIBERAL FRAUD.
HE SPENT 20 YEARS HAS A CURRENT
LEVEL DEMOCRAT SUPPORTING
NANCY PELOSI, JOHN KERRY,
RALLYING FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
>> MORRISSEY LOCKED HORNS LAST
NIGHT WITH JENKINS OVER
REGULATIONS.
>> OUR LAWSUIT GOT TO STAY.
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE YOUR FAX.
>> MORE TO COME ON THIS.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> YOUR NEW JERSEY APPROACH.
WANTING TO LET ME FINISH.
>> JENKINS REMINDS REPUBLICANS
MORRISSEY RAN FOR CONGRESS IN
NEW JERSEY AT THE
TURN-OF-THE-CENTURY.
HE ALSO DENIGRATES MORRISSEY AS
SOMEONE WITH NEW JERSEY VALUES.
>> YES, I CALLED HIM OUT AND
KIND OF A FUN WAY OF THE DEBATE
LAST NIGHT BECAUSE HE WAS JUST A
PUSHY, KIND OF JERSEY VALUES
APPROACH.
HE IS JERSEY THROUGH AND THROUGH
BY HIS OWN ADMISSION.
>> HERE IN THE MOUNTAIN STATE,
NOT MUCH LOVE FOR THE GARDEN
STATE.
CANDIDATES ARE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME TO CHANGE VOTERS' MINDS
BECAUSE EARLY VOTING STARTS
TODAY.
THAT MEANS SOME WEST VIRGINIA'S
HAVE HEARD ENOUGH AND THEY ARE
CASTING BALLOTS AND CANNOT BE